moving on now to Sudan where the UN says
a mass grave containing at least 87
bodies has been discovered in the west
R4 region the victims were reportedly
members of an ethnic minority group the
un's human rights office condemned the
killings and said it had credible
information that the rapid support
forces were responsible the rsf
paramilitary group is fighting the Army
for control of Sudan
and Egypt is hosting the leaders of
Sudan's neighbors to discuss ways to end
that conflict but the warring Sudanese
factions have not been invited Egyptian
president Abdel fattah al-sisi is
hosting the leaders of Ethiopia South
Sudan Chad Eritrea Libya and the Central
African Republic they're trying to come
up with ways to bring peace to Sudan the
fighting which began in mid-april has
displaced more than 2.4 million people
and more than 700 000 700 000 rather
have crossed into neighboring countries
meanwhile the head of the United Nations
mission to Sudan says the government has
lost control of the country and the
confidence in the region speaking to Al
Jazeera Volker perfeirs reiterated the
UN support for any initiative to find a
diplomatic solution to the conflict
the current government lost control of
the situation in the country they lost
the trust of the neighboring countries
in the final communique of igad there
was no mention of the government versus
the rapid support forces but they only
talked about the Army and the rapid
support forces they said that they are
sorry that the Army didn't attend the
meeting from this perspective this
decision clearly shows that this is not
about sending armed peacekeeping troops
but more of assessing the situation
while keeping in mind the possibility of
having to intervene for humanitarian
reasons
and joining me in the studio is Ellen
Boswell he's the Horn of Africa director
at the international crisis group Alan
thanks so much for joining me on the
program
how hopeful can we be that this meeting
in Egypt will make any difference to the
conflict as we just reported it's been
happening since mid-april
yeah uh not very hopeful unfortunately
um the only people who've been able to
bring the two warring parties themselves
together thus far have been the United
States and Saudi Arabia but those talks
have basically been suspended now uh for
weeks we've had a flurry of diplomatic
activity as different different Regional
States and different external powers are
trying to grab the mediation mantle but
unfortunately we've seen very little
progress in actually creating a
ceasefire in far too much competition
among all these different external
Powers about who can take the lead on it
um but none of these tracks have really
any traction yet what impact is this
conflict having on the region more
broadly and particularly those bordering
countries where we've seen such an
influx of of people fleeing this
conflict it's having a huge impact Sudan
sits you know really uh at a Crossroads
between the Sahel and the Horn of Africa
the Mediterranean and the Red Sea a lot
of the neighbors you know are very
unstable themselves they've faced a huge
influx of refugees but they also face a
whole array of security issues and
there's a lot of cross-border links as
well I think one of the under
appreciated parts of this conflict has
just been the mass of sort of sucking a
hole that a sudan collapse will have in
the broader region it will have huge
ramifications for probably decades
we've learned today of the discovery of
a mass grave in the west Darfur region I
mean that surely has an impact on how
these peace negotiations or discussions
will unfold yeah it's sadly not too much
of a surprise
um that this Mass grave has been found
the reports of essentially Mass
atrocities of the sorts that we saw in
Darfur 20 years ago those have been
coming out pretty steadily now for weeks
as as you know from from the border but
it is raising the question among
diplomats uh can you negotiate really a
peace deal with the rapid support forces
who are implicated in some of these
atrocities or are they basically now too
damaged too bad in a way to negotiate
with but the problem is is no one has a
better idea of how to try to get peace
because the rsf in many ways has gained
the upper hand in the battle for cartoon
and can you explain to us this
ethnic violence the ethnic violence
that's really seems to be taking a hold
in this conflict
yeah so uh Darfur in many ways has its
own conflict Dynamics
um the west of Sudan we were concerned
as crisis group when this conflict broke
out that one of the one of the major
concerns with Sudan has had Conflict for
many decades and we'd see some of these
old conflicts some of which had subsided
but we'd see them re-erupting and
essentially that's what we're seeing now
in Sudan uh it's not just fighting
between the rsf and the Army like we've
seen in Khartoum it involves fighting
between essentially Arab identifying
communities and non-arab communities
some of these tensions go back two
decades um yeah and we're really seeing
the worst some of the reports sound very
much like ethnic cleansing all right
well we really appreciate you explaining
a complex issue so essentially Ellen
Boswell from the Horn of Africa director
at the international crisis group thanks
for your time thanks Emily